and coming over here you realize nothing
matters but Liberty and these ideas and
values that surround democracy and
freedom and so ultimately
we my commander said this to me he said
Sarah we're not fighting for tolerance
here or acceptance we're fighting for
Liberation we're fighting for life and
death and we're fighting for this idea
of freedom and that stuck with me
forever we're not fighting any sort of
War of identity we're fighting for our
lives and we're fighting to make sure
we're not enslaved here
[Music]
thank you
it is my privilege to Welcome to the
podcast from Curson Ukraine journalist
War correspondent enlisted soldier in
the Ukrainian Army all-around hero in my
book Sarah Ashton Cirillo welcome Sarah
hey Andrew it's great to be on the show
and yeah that's a lot of stuff that had
roll off your tongue regarding my
different professional undertakings here
in Ukraine yeah you and I met out in Las
Vegas uh you were in uh a more normal
role I would say uh and now you're doing
something that most of us uh only get
glimpses of in terms of news coverage
and social media Clips you're actually a
source of a lot of the social media
clips and I'd urge people to follow
Sarah Ashton Cirillo's accounts because
you get an underground look from curse
on and other parts of Ukraine how did
you find yourself in a war zone over
this last nearly year now it's
interesting that's the question I get
often and it's something that morphed
it was a slow time I was covering the US
political scene specifically in Nevada
where I want to say the forward parties
had a lot of success and you personally
are always warmly welcomed in the great
state of Nevada
and the
full-scale Invasion took place in
February February 24th and on March 4th
I arrived for two weeks to cover the
refugee crisis specifically in the
Border area between Poland and Ukraine
it's something I'd written about before
in 2015 with the Syrian refugee crisis
and after arriving when I came to the
Ukrainian side in order to get my
credentials from the Armed Forces of
Ukraine I was given the opportunity to
go to the northern Frontline city of
right after the Russians had been pushed
out at March 9th March 10th I arrived
there and I didn't leave harkiv for more
than seven and a half months
I started volunteering with the Armed
Forces I went ahead and was covering the
war for lgbtq nation for six months as a
journalist and eventually I started
working in a civilian capacity for the
Ukrainian government and eventually
enlisted on October 10th
uh you served as a medic uh in the
Ukrainian Army until quite recently
where they moved you to something called
hybrid Warfare and you've also been on
Capitol Hill uh communicating to members
of Congress about the importance of
American Support uh you must have seen
some harrowing things as a medic I'm
imagining even before serving I saw some
of the most horrific images that will
never leave me as a journalist and as a
volunteer
I saw enough death
to last I never want to see another I
don't care if it's Ukrainian or even a
Russian die in this War I want every
death to be the last death
because what we've experienced here over
the last 11 months what I've experienced
personally in
dozens dozens of
of of casualties
and we can get to that point if the
Russians would just withdraw and if we
can get back to the 1991 borders and see
Justice serve then we don't have to have
any more deaths on either side so you
share a story about when you arrived in
Ukraine uh you were concerned about
admission because you had a passport
that looked nothing like you uh because
you are transgender and your passport
had what was out of date uh and looked
uh like you did several years ago uh can
you can you share that story because I I
have to feel like that must have been
also uh something of uh an ordeal it was
a huge psychological ordeal in the sense
of wondering if I would even enter the
Ukrainian side as you mentioned I am
transgender
I had all of my documentation in Nevada
my my different markers my name
everything changed well before I
traveled my driver's license looked like
me Etc however because of the different
limitations with covid uh with the slow
processing of the passport agencies I
just never bothered to send it off
and that's very sensible over this past
several years you're like Hey we're like
what am I going to be taking trips
abroad
exactly and ultimately it was a snap
decision that I made to come over here
because I didn't believe that there
would be a war I didn't believe Vladimir
Putin would be so stupid as to invade
Ukraine uh a full-scale invasion you had
invaded previously in 2014. and so I
took the opportunity took the chance I
knew flying into the EU specifically
Germany I wouldn't have any problems
Once I arrived at the Ukrainian border
with Poland
I made the decision to go for it thanks
to encouragement from some other
journalists
and so we aborted a train that it was
myself three other journalists and a
bunch of returning ukrainians who were
coming back to serve in the military
so on the train
what should have been an hour and 20
minute trip
turn into five hours and 45 minutes of
the delay
was getting to the Ukrainian border
in the inside the train and Security
Services not knowing what to do with me
I had come prepared I brought some of
the different write-ups that had taken
place about me Washington Post Daily
Beast shown some of my book sales from
Amazon my writings Etc to show hey this
is me I'm not trying to sneak into the
country during war
and they made me
they made me strip down
um not the private areas but they made
me strip down to check to see if I
really
was in the process of transitioning and
after doing so they said welcome to
Ukraine
and while
a lot of people in the different
communities uh said that that was you
know something that I should have been
angry about for me I was overjoyed that
they let me in I mean they allowed me in
with a different passport during the
middle of a war and that's when I
realized that this country was going to
win and on their way to winning because
they were not being held back just like
the forward parties not being held back
by traditional thinking the Ukrainian
Security Services were not being held
back by preconceived notions of of who
and what and and how they could move
forward in winning this war with Russia
yeah you've commented that uh the only
things people care about in Ukraine are
your character uh your actions your
behavior your commitment uh and things
around your identity uh are not on
anyone's mind and you describe that as
actually a different set of experiences
than you have in the U.S
yes very much so when you ran your
different campaigns you had to overcome
stigma and stereotyping and when people
who are living with different gender
identities in the United States
especially now it seems to be on both
sides if you're talking the the left and
the right it becomes a bludgeon to
utilize against one another
and coming over here you realize nothing
matters but Liberty and these ideas and
values that surround democracy and
freedom and so ultimately
we my commander said this to me he said
Sarah we're not fighting for tolerance
here or acceptance we're fighting for
Liberation we're fighting for life and
death and we're fighting for this idea
of freedom and that stuck with me
forever we're not fighting any sort of
War of identity we're fighting for our
lives and we're fighting to make sure
we're not enslaved here
you know that's an incredible
perspective that only a country under
attack uh could have so you cross the
border uh you show up in carvieve as a
journalist
um how do you live day to day uh like
when you show up was there housing I'd
imagine that taking care of journalists
isn't that high on the priority list of
of of the the military folks and you've
been there for months like how like how
do you go about what people would
consider a routine
this is really unique and this has
raised some eyebrows
um I was brought to harqui by Security
Services
and it was a random event after I had
been accredited where
two people heard me speaking English
and they were it turned out they were
with security services and one of them
said all of our all the journalists are
leaving parkeev if you want to see the
war and you want to report on the war we
will bring you to harakiv but we're
leaving in an hour and I was in the
obelis just south of obelista's region I
was in the region just south of leviv
called Ivano francives
and I spoke to somebody there who I
trusted someone a medical doctor who I
was there to interview
and she confirmed that they were who
they said they were and she told me if
this is true and all the journalists are
leaving you need to go
because this is a chance to show the
world what's happening
so I got
it's it's ridiculous to think about I
got into a car with these strange men
and drove across country
about a thousand kilometers so 650 miles
to within 20 miles of the Russian border
in the middle of
this insane combat attacks on us yeah
insane combat and so for about a month
and a half I was fully embedded with
these people living with them and
I was in this weird bubble Andrew where
the War was happening around me in a
macro scale and even in harkive on on
some sort of bigger level and I was in
focused with this tunnel vision because
I was only reporting on what I was being
shown by them and I was seeing amazing
uh happenings by the Ukrainian military
a lot of it I couldn't report and
it's the best thing that ever happened I
was getting frustrated on occasion
because this wider story was out there
and I was only focused on the people I
was with
but it turned out that it was the best
thing that ever happened to me because
it prepared me to be a war correspondent
it was almost sort of like boot camp you
understand the realities of war and so
after I moved out on my own which was in
May so I got there on March I got to the
region on March 9th got to the city on
March 10th by the first week of May I
moved out on my own
and after that it was just normal living
I had an apartment I was living in a
very
um it was an area called North saltifa
which was the most attacked neighborhood
of any of the unoccupied areas of of the
country and I was living on the 13th
floor and I'm watching the war around me
from the 13th floor and
watching the Rockets literally come in
several times doing live reports on my
balcony Rockets hit within a couple of
hundred meters one time it hit 100
meters away in a building right in front
of me and so ultimately
you learn to live with it and you learn
to understand the acceptance of what we
sign up for as journalists on the front
lines and what that means is if we're
going to show the truth to the world we
have to be willing to to pay whatever
the sacrifice is and there's been more
than 30 journalists who have died at the
hands of the Russian terrorism and so I
want to give my regards to to their
memory and and to their families and and
so many more have been injured for me
many times it came close but they never
got me and that's one of the areas that
pushed me thinking wise into joining the
military because it was nearly as
dangerous for me as a journalist as it
would be for me to serve
foreign
if you know me you know that I believe
we should own our own data and right now
big tech companies are tracking your
every move online one way you can
improve this situation is to use
expressvpn I like expressvpn and use it
on several devices you can use it for
under seven bucks a month after all I
don't want my personal data to get
access for the profit of someone else
plus I like being able to access content
from around the world just literally tap
one button on your device to turn it on
and you're done no more big companies
snooping around my business if you don't
like big Tech tracking you and selling
your personal data for profit it's time
to fight back visit
expressvpn.com yang right now to get
three months of expressvpn for free
that's
expressvpn.com Yang once more
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
[Music]
so you joined the military uh got
weapons training uh and have been trying
to save lives as a medic uh and I think
at some point they realized that uh you
had enormous talents uh in terms of
public awareness and Communications and
thinking and writing what is the
American public missing like are are
there things that are happening on the
ground uh that uh would surprise folks
who just tune into mainstream news
coverage yes and there's a big one and
it's refrain that the American public
oftentimes hears but it's something that
I would love for them all to see and I'm
trying to create a program where it's
called hello Ukraine and I spoke to you
briefly about that where we would bring
people over to see what's really
happening there's been no greater return
on investment than what the U.S tax
dollars are going towards in Ukraine in
the last 80 years of foreign policy and
yet what they would need to see is how
much more we need
giving us little Drip by Drip by drip of
of sourcing of weapons humanitarian Aid
and civilian Aid is it great and we're
appreciative but at the same point we
could end this war in one to two months
if we were able to get everything on the
wish list now and so sometimes it feels
like we're fighting as an Insurgent Army
even though we're fighting with the best
weapons yeah yeah we're defending it and
we're making do with in ways that NATO
standard troops could never imagine
and there's a great Point that's in a
congressional research paper
where it was talking about amphibious
vehicles for the United States Marine
Corps
the United States has learned so much
about Russian weaknesses that we've been
able to in the United States modify some
of our thinking based on what the
Ukrainian armed forces have been able to
carry out here what we're doing here
with U.S tax dollars is advancing U.S
knowledge in the areas of defense and
Warfare by decades versus what they
would be learning in simulations and so
what I could tell the U.S taxpayers
is your support is not going to waste
and if you could just stay with us and
tell your Congress people to get us the
weapons we need all of them right now
we will end this war and Destroy Russia
as a threat forever that's a very
powerful message and something that uh
our lawmakers need to hear I will say uh
I 100 believe that any investment to
support Ukrainian defense is has a
better Roi than anything else that we
could be doing uh if you imagine another
world where Russia were to steamroll
Ukraine uh I think about the costs of
that world not just in human costs which
are the obvious ones but but also of the
message it sends to China and others you
might consider various aggressive uh
acts
um and then the reverse that if you can
remove Russia as a global threat uh that
would be
Monumental uh historic and uh it's more
a product of Ukrainian courage and
sacrifice obviously than anything that
uh is being sent to the country by the
American government how would you
describe the Ukrainian people from your
nearly year there I've never been around
a group of people more certain in their
beliefs
and more willing to carry them out than
the Ukrainian people you talk about
morale of course the morale waxes and
wanes because we're surrounded by Death
but no one has lost the belief in
Victory and this has been amazing they
talk about folks in the west being tired
of of the conflict
people are tired here but they are still
fully energized and fully focused on
winning and so I become inspired
it doesn't even have to be at the front
lines I could be in the middle of the
country and I see somebody living in
darkness and become inspired by them
knowing that they are chopping firewood
when they were living with electricity
two weeks ago chopping firewood to stay
warm and not complaining they're going
forward ready and willing to sacrifice
in whatever way
not just militarily in order to find
Victory and liberate their country and
that's I think one of the greatest
Follies that people are making
is trying to compare this to any other
foreign intervention by the United
States uh in the last 80 years because
ultimately this is an ally who has been
invaded on their territory
has had a what was known at one time as
the second greatest army in the world we
now know the Russian army is is really
worthless and useless except to carry
out terrorism
and so
this conflict this war this battle
in no way can be judged by anything
that's happened since World War II
and the Ukrainian people are fighting it
as if it was a World War because you
have Iranian drones coming in at them
you have North Korean armaments coming
in at them you have Belarus and Russia
launching attacks at us or Russia
launching attacks from Belarusian
territory at us and so ultimately you
have these different countries that are
all coming at Ukraine
and it's the Ukrainian people that are
standing strong against this tyranny and
against these tyrants you are an
American uh risking your life in Ukraine
I admire you a great deal as I'm sure
anyone listening to this does
um are there people from around the
world who are showing up in Ukraine you
just described kind of the uh assemblage
of forces against uh Ukraine
um has there been a similar rally on the
other side absolutely there's a core
group of and and for security reasons I
can't say the number there's a core
group of
fighters who have come over willing to
sign contracts not as mercenaries we
don't have mercenaries here people who
are signing contracts directly with the
Ukrainian Armed Forces fighting on
behalf of Ukraine taking this oath to
defend Ukraine not giving up their
belief in their Nation I'm very proud to
be from the United States and the United
States is my my home but we are choosing
to sign up and and pledge our honor and
our courage to Ukraine in order to fight
back against this worldwide tyranny and
so ultimately you have it in the
military and then you have this
tremendous tremendous outpouring of
people who have come over as civilian
volunteers from places such as Canada
the Baltic countries you have uh great
people coming from the United States
from Australia and so the civilian
volunteer network be it through
Logistics be it through supplies or even
through Hands-On Medical work is really
something that is humbling to know how
these people are risking their lives for
this fight for freedom
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I've always been into sleep as one of
the best ways you can invest in your own
health and the way you can sleep better
is by getting a new mattress from Helix
sleep just take a personalized quiz at
helixsleep.com and they will send you a
mattress out of their 14 individual
mattress types that will give you the
sleep of your life and if you don't like
it you can return it risk-free for up to
a hundred nights I know it's bananas
Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress pick by GQ wired and my kids
who seek it out it's their favorite
mattress in the house and there are some
mattresses that frankly I spent more
money on than the Helix mattress Helix
is offering up to 350 off that's a
bigger amount than ever all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com slash
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
now I I regard zielinski as a symbol uh
an example of Courage at the highest
levels I mean clearly his life has been
in Jeopardy from uh the beginning uh I
I've been surprised by something of what
I I think is a disinformation or
misinformation campaign in the U.S where
there is some conservatives that seem to
be painting this conflict in a
particular light saying conservatives I
mean I think most conservatives are very
much aligned at Ukraine's defense is
vital
um but I I it it seems to me that that
there is like a Russian campaign to try
and Seed some kind of counter narrative
uh and I I know you
are plugged in in terms of the
Ukrainian military and its
Communications is there a sense that
there's a Russian effort to so uh
discontent uh among American supporters
of Ukraine absolutely and and we have
factual proof of this Andrea and it
didn't just start on February 24th it
didn't just start eight years ago
it started more than two decades ago
when the Russians really gave up this
idea that Ukraine was a free nation and
truly just a vassal state that belonged
to them and so they were coming in
trying to buy media companies trying to
push out this free media and then you
can look uh back to 2014 which is when
some of the first
foreign
but the first narratives started to pop
up in Google Trends
in order to create this false notion of
what Ukraine is or was
and then it happened again on February
24th and what the Russians do is they
seed it because they they're very good
at this part of warfare they go ahead
and they seed it somewhere they'll put
it into an alternative media source and
then two three four months later they'll
pop it up from an official standpoint
and say look the media was already
reporting on this
a few months ago so we know what they do
we know how they do it the key point is
being able to amplify this message back
to the world this free thinking world
that's not being pulled in and sucked in
by the propaganda of the Russian
terrorists
and be able to get them to understand
hey these talking points are not just uh
funny but they're malicious and they're
an attempt to influence
not just the war in Ukraine but the
overall Global Narrative of what freedom
and democracy is I publish something not
too long ago regarding the Russian
interference in the elections and
without rehashing everything to do with
the the Mueller report it's very clear
that the Russians were behind this and
the head of the Wagner group progression
who was indicted by the FBI in 2020 for
election interference
went ahead and admitted in November of
2022 that he did in fact manipulate U.S
elections and he's looking back on it
now with no no concern he's never going
to be arrested hopefully what we'll do
at Xena zoo at the Armed Forces of
Ukraine is we'll kill him and if
progression is listening to this you're
a dead man the Wagner group are dead
people we are going to eradicate the
scourge of these mercenaries coming out
of Russia but getting back to the
standpoint of disinformation he admitted
in November of 2022 what the U.S accused
him of since 2014 which is meddling in
the elections yeah they are very very
good at these uh disinformation
campaigns and are they they're long-term
about it
um I but I I have been surprised at uh
how
uh persistent these efforts have been I
instinctively have been the whole time
that uh we have to back Ukraine uh this
is as close to a uh like a malevolent
dictator
invading a neighbor and and having their
their uh Armed Forces uh act as a
terrorist Force
um over months and I'd imagine they
thought that Ukraine would capitulate
quite quickly and and now uh ukrainians
have dug in
um
uh and it's it's really heroic one of
the things that you put out recently
made me incredibly sad
um which was uh a report that it's going
to take decades to clear Ukraine of uh
ordinances and landmines uh because the
Russians have populated the countryside
with them that's a kind of real life
thing that uh makes you realize just how
long term the damage is going to be
there's tens of thousands of acres of
land that is no longer arable no longer
used for growing food and Ukraine has
been considered for Generations as the
breadbasket of Europe and so every time
I would see on the news about this in
Fargo or not being able to ship grain
out
while that in itself is an immediate
concern
the bigger concern is what happens
during next sewing season when we're not
even able to go ahead and implant these
crops
in Carson which is one of the reasons I
came down
was to see some of these armaments left
behind by the Russians as they ran away
and in addition to the video you saw we
found live grenades there's landmines
there's tripwires
Etc the Russians tried to terrorize even
on their way out when they made this uh
made this escape from Carson across the
river from where we are
and people die there's a volunteer who
died in September drove over a landline
people die all the time it's not
reported and this is yesterday when we
lost in in may all of the people who
died in yesterday's helicopter crash
especially the children in the
kindergarten uh may they rest in peace
and may they have
um Peace in their hearts and souls for
their family
when it was said that it was the
Russians it's because it was the
Russians there was a blackout in the
city the aviation lights were not
working and it was foggy on the top of
the buildings Russian terrorism led to
the uh helicopter crash Russian
terrorism leads to these deaths at the
uh in the fields when Farmers drive over
them with tractors which happens and yet
because we live in this 24-hour news
cycle as you well know
a one-off of somebody driving over a
landline doesn't capture the attention
the way it would anywhere else in the
world if we were not fighting in
uh basically I'll call it what could be
on the verge of being a World War and so
ultimately
that's what we were trying to get some
of the messaging out about and there's
others who who take
far greater efforts in taking care of it
there's an American volunteer Ryan
Hendrickson who comes over from Florida
he's does landmine removal a true hero
there's the Ukrainian sappers who that's
their whole job is to remove these
unexploded ordinances for me
I was shown it and I'm used to it in
hierarchy of where we have so much land
and because it was on the border area I
would work as close as 500 to 700 meters
from the Russian border for several
months in hanukkieve I probably spent
more time on the Russian border than any
other Foreigner since this full-scale
invasion
and going up to the Russian border
there's landmine warning signs
everywhere because the Russians on their
way out again when they were treated
because they had been in the heart of
region when they were treated they
destroyed the crops in the land
and it's something that
stays heavy on all of our hearts and
minds and and something that as Ryan
jumped into the thread yesterday that
you're referring to we could be looking
at uh five decades before it ever gets
cleared up
yeah well Ryan uh is Another Hero it's
true I mean you make me feel better
about being an American uh Ryan does uh
as well I feel like the least America
can do is uh support people like you and
the Ukrainian people who are laying
their lives on the line every single day
uh in pursuit of just human Freedom uh
and resistance to tyranny so you came
back to DC to talk to members of
Congress uh how did that go it went
extremely well I think think when I
arrived because the ministry of Defense
wanted my itinerary I think I had six
meetings set up all of them very
important enough for me to fly over by
the time I had left by the time I had
met up with you in New York City I had
met with over 20 different legislative
offices several different committees as
well as speaking at some think tanks and
after meeting with you for some coffee
in New York I ended up going back to DC
for more meetings because the message
had resonated so greatly on a bipartisan
level with the lawmakers in in
Washington and I can say on behalf of
the Armed Forces of Ukraine and
ukrainians everywhere we are so grateful
for the support from a bipartisan sense
in the United States Congress and we
understand just how important the U.S
legislators are to this fight for
victory yeah this needs to be
nonpartisan or bipartisan uh I think
traditionally uh it would have been but
you're heading to DC I'm sure is very
very compelling and Powerful I mean as
an American who's on the front uh with
such uh direct authoritative perspective
and the same way that zielinski has this
moral Authority
um you do too uh and Ryan and anyone
who's heading to a war zone especially
in your case because you don't need to
be there I've become as close to
apolitical as one can be and you have to
when you're in a situation like this I
pay attention now obviously to the
bigger issues of what we're facing on a
global scale but a lot of what's
happening in the United States while
still very important to the people going
through it I now realize whether it's an
issue on the right or the left I can't
necessarily involve myself in commentary
you know and comment on it unless it's
extremely egregious because we can't
take our Focus off of this this fight
that we're in this war against Russian
aggression and so when I got to DC I
spoke with some very conservative folks
and I spoke with some very liberal folks
and it was okay because all of us were
focused on how we can beat Russia and
that was such an encouraging sign for me
that people could put aside maybe
preconceived notions of who I was but
more importantly people could put aside
any sort of partisan bickering for truly
this greater good and after Victory what
I hope the United States Congress takes
out of this is that they can come and
find Solutions and and find a way to
bring prosperity to the United States
and a greater prosperity to the United
States and re-establish themselves as
this moral Authority in global events
and Global Affairs because of what
they've managed to succeed with the
Ukrainian people here well it takes
leadership like yours to demonstrate how
trivial uh the back and forth issues are
in the context of life or death struggle
for democracy Humanity civilization so
let's
um let's say everything goes as well as
it can where the the American people and
anyone who's watching this please do
express your support for the people of
Ukraine they're still fighting and dying
and reach out to your lawmakers and
express the the fact that you think it's
vital that Russia is defeated and
ejected let's say that you were to get
the resources you need
um Russia
essentially it Retreats or capitulates
and I'm sure they try and put a positive
face on it for their own people their
own sake but uh but but they're defeated
uh do you think that there should be an
international effort to invest in the uh
the rebuilding of Ukraine because I'm
sure you see the devastation of War
around you all the time
absolutely and one of the things in
areas of rebuilding that I hope people
understand after this is the technical
Ingenuity of the Ukrainian people is
second to none and when we have people
like yourself entrepreneurs who
understand how to rebuild that's who we
need to rely on as well as International
organizations
I'll sound like the Chamber of Commerce
here but Ukraine is going to be open for
business and it's not just an agrarian
society it's not just a society of these
brave warriors it's a society of some of
the most highly educated
forward-looking internationally focused
people even before the full scale
Invasion and the opportunity that's
going to take place here for any
entrepreneurs as well as Nations that
want to solidify their alliances and
move forward in a way that creates as I
said earlier with the United States
creates Prosperity there's no better
country than Ukraine this is being able
to take a blank slate to whatever the
dreams are that people could imagine for
an economy as we head towards 2050 that
can take place here and it's not just
politicians that we want coming over to
Ukraine we want Business Leaders we want
entrepreneurs to come over and see for
themselves the opportunities folks can
come to Levy folks can come to Kiev and
it's safe uh and then as the different
cities open up as we liberate places
like Carson where I am right now or
heart cave which has been liberated now
for a few months then you can see
different opportunities open up there
the ports are are here we have
incredible natural resources but most
importantly we have people power and
highly educated Workforce here
well it sounds like after uh the
Warriors the Chamber of Commerce might
make you an offer
uh and you know hopefully for all of our
sakes we we get there
so that there are a lot of people who
want to support the efforts in Ukraine
um but there's also a lot of mistrust
and confusion out there if someone does
want to support uh the people on the
ground
um how can they they do so is there an
organization a link that you promote
absolutely but before I get to that
point I would like to just make one
statement to rebut anyone who says
there's waste or other words which I
won't repeat here on the air when it
comes to Aid to Ukraine there's more
than 60 different oversight projects
going on just from the executive branch
of government right now between the
state department or the U.S executive
branch between the state department the
Pentagon and usaid there's 63 different
committees that are looking into
oversight of Aid to Ukraine and so
people can rest assured that when their
money is sent to Ukraine it's being used
it's not being siphoned off it's being
used in this battle for Liberty because
if not the ukrainians become enslaved by
a Russian dictator I would suggest
Liberty Ukraine which is a group made up
of what I call resistance fighters in
Austin Texas and New Jersey
they're all Ukrainian Nationals who had
immigrated and found great success in
the United States and now give almost
all of their time back to their Homeland
and so this group Liberty Ukraine I I
can send you the link but that's who I
would suggest they've sent over
um more than 30 000 pounds of supplies
to both the military and civilian
populace and it ships right out of New
Jersey well that that sounds ideal uh
and I love the idea of uh Ukrainian
diaspora trying to help the Homeland I
think I speak for everyone I say first
and foremost stay safe Sarah uh we you
know you're we we we certainly uh need
you to come back home and and be able to
continue to share your story uh I dare
say that there is going to be a movie
about you after all this is said and
done we should uh think about who's
going to play you
um but you you are in in the uh
immediate present you are an author
um you're putting out videos as to
what's happening in Ukraine how can
people uh follow you and support you
personally if you go to Twitter or
Instagram
Sarah Ashton Sarah with an h s a r a h
Ashton LV stands for Las Vegas on
Twitter and Instagram
and I also have a sub stack that I
sometimes put interesting nuggets on and
that's Sarah Ashton Cirillo and sub
stack
and speaking of Las Vegas and I don't
want to bring it back to domestic policy
except voting is an internationally
important voting rights internationally
important topic congratulations to the
forward party in Las Vegas for passing
the first step in getting ranked Choice
voting and top five voting into the
Nevada constitution it doesn't matter
what party you're involved in it's not a
partisan issue just like War isn't and
another reason we're fighting this war
is so people can make free choices
whether it's president zielinski or
anyone else on who's going to represent
them and we want the same thing
everywhere in the world
yeah some of your friends in Nevada were
integral to that campaign and it really
was the people of Nevada saying we'd
like to determine our own future please
uh so it was uh invigorating and
inspiring to be a part of that we have
to do it again in 2024 most people know
because of the way the Nevada
constitution
um so uh who knows Sarah you might be
there there with us uh you'll you'll be
a returning hero uh and then people will
attend massive rallies in your honor and
then you will say yeah vote Yes odd
question uh whatever the heck it's going
to be on this ballot in 2024. I have a
vision that's going to come to pass
you'll be there I'll be there and there
will be a crowd of uh of raucous adoring
uh nevadans I'll say this and I know we
have to wrap it up in a moment I'm just
a soldier who's following orders and
trying to fight for freedom and whether
it was you as a mayor or as our
commander-in-chief or Governor Whitman
wherever you guys say we need to to pop
up to be able to push pun intended
forward with with Liberty on the United
States I think there's many of us ready
to go and fight for it well you're
leading by example in the most powerful
way you can Sarah really please please
please stay safe and anyone who wants to
follow and support Sarah's work uh
follow her on social media sub stack she
writes at Resolute square but yeah let's
bring her home and the best way to do
that is to end this war thank you so
much for the time Andrew have a
wonderful afternoon so great to see you
my friend
thank you
[Music]